I really started to pay attention you
know um in the in the Obama years and I
am telling you when I watched the
movement I watch the system I see how
mob-like that they're acting very
Machiavelli and very mob-like I'll give
you the the one uh uh phrase from
Machiavelli he says he was advising his
Prince you read the book you know that
she's advising him how to maintain
control of his kingdom and he tells the
prince you can do anything you need to
do you can lie you can steal you can
cheat you can even kill to maintain
control that's the number one thing but
to the outside world you must always
appear to be honest upright and have
integrity and that's our politicians
today